with fewer content restrictions than an
mcu film and more room to flesh out its
characters one of the best parts of
marvel's netflix series was its villains
from ninjas to mercenaries from maniacs
to crime lords here are the mcu's
netflix villains ranked from worst to
best
the hand is a criminal organizations
whose shuriken tossing soldiers have
been leaping through marvel's comics for
a long time and they make their presence
felt in half of marvel's netflix
offerings while making them an integral
part of charlie cox's daredevil story is
accurate to the source material you
could argue that in the mcu netflix
series they were a big part of the
series drop in quality the netflix
heroes were best when dealing with
challenges grounded in the real world
daredevil's greatest villain is a crime
lord kristin ritter's jessica jones
wrestles with the trauma she endured
from a sexual predator and john
bernthal's frank castle goes up against
corrupt soldiers for hire in the
punisher's first season these are all
exaggerated versions of people who sadly
exist in the real world making a
centuries-old clandestine organization
filled with ninjas and super-powered
warriors brought the narrative to a
place that felt more like a fantasy
yeah a little bit
when it comes to bad guys you can't go
wrong with clancy brown the man who
famously played the merciless kurgan in
1986's highlander shows up in season 2
of daredevil as colonel ray skudover he
is one of the men responsible for the
death of frank castle's family as one of
the leaders of the cerberus squad
schooner secretly funneled heroin from
afghanistan to the united states in
order to line his pockets the colonel's
low placement on the list is only
because we hardly get to know him
schooner shows up for only two episodes
of daredevil and in his second
appearance he becomes one of frank
castle's victims brown briefly reprises
the role for flashbacks in the first
season of the punisher he's great at
conveying the feel of a once proud
officer who's now a slave to his need
for power and wealth but unfortunately
we only get so much time with him before
castle gives him what he deserves
willis striker aka diamondback is played
by eric larae harvey and he starts off
strong he first appears halfway through
luke cage's inaugural season and he
quickly becomes the biggest threat to
the titular hero it's striker who brings
the hammer industries tech into harlem
to fight luke cage this includes the
judas bullets the only ammo capable of
piercing cage's skin and the suit of
body armor he wears to fight cage in the
season 1 finale of all the antagonists
in that first season he's the only one
who presents any kind of physical
challenge to cage but in part it's the
physical threat to cage that ruins
diamondback his iron man light suit is
just about the goofiest looking thing in
the entire luke cage series contrasts
sharply against a show otherwise set in
a world that doesn't feel too far
removed from the real one their big
brawl at the end of the first season
while engaging can take you out of the
story faster than just about anything
else in the series
shawande played by babs olasanbukun is
one of the founders of the hand and as
one of the so-called five fingers of the
hand shawande has had his life extended
for centuries and he hasn't been idle in
that time shawande is a master of
martial arts without any superhuman
strength backing him up he's able to
make short work of luke cage through the
manipulation of pressure points in the
defenders and he's likewise undefeated
by iron fist but despite his martial
arts prowess shawanda is one of the more
forgettable villains of mcu's netflix
series he lives and dies within the only
season of the defenders beheaded by
daredevil's mentor stick played by scott
glenn and denied the immortal life that
he and the other leaders of the hand
crave if most of the defenders is best
left forgotten and it is then shawande
has a head start pun intended
elodie young's portrayal of elektra
nachios in season 2 of daredevil is one
of the bright spots in the weakest of
the show's three seasons young perfectly
embodies the deadly warrior who's both
in love with matthew murdock and wants
him to adopt less merciful tactics in
his role as daredevil with her multiple
deaths and resurrections in the source
material a tragic death and a dark
return were all but guaranteed even so
it's after her resurrection in the
defenders that this warrior loses her
spark when she is brought back to life
in the defenders elektra may still be
good at fighting and killing but she
simply isn't as compelling a character
as alexandra reads right hand woman
elektra is practically mindless not
truly emerging from her
post-resurrection haze until she kills
reed it's possible we could have seen a
more interesting version of elektra as a
villain if daredevil had continued but
unfortunately her final appearance is in
the series finale of the defenders
the bride of nine spiders played by jane
kim proves a worthy opponent for danny
rand in season 1 of iron fist the
seductive and skilled martial artist
comes close to defeating the hero but
compared to the other villains on the
list the bride has a couple of things
working against her first we never see
the bride again after immortal emerges
from cave giving her a distinct villain
of the week feel second while we
normally don't automatically fall to
series from diverting from the source
material the bride is a special case in
the comics we first meet the bride in
2007's immortal iron fist number eight
as part of a tournament with the
champions of all the immortal cities
when it's her turn to fight in the arena
the bride displays the impressive and
terrifying ability to summon seemingly
endless swarms of spiders at her
opponents adapting the character without
that ability especially considering the
incredible visuals it could have led to
feels
criminal
theo rossi has a knack for getting
memorable roles with unique nicknames on
sons of anarchy rossi played the biker
juice while on luke cage he played one
of the series most interesting crooks
shades in the first season shades is
fairly low in the stokes crime family
pecking order but even then there's a
lot going on behind the lenses of his
namesake while people like cottonmouth
played by mahershala ali and mariah
dillard played by alfred woodard may be
the one sitting on harlem's throne at
any given time it shades manipulating
things behind the curtain in the second
season shades moves up the ladder owing
in no small part to his romance with
dillard his cool facade finally cracks
when dillard forces him to kill his true
love comanche played by thomas q jones
it puts him on the path of betraying
dillard but he remains the same
charismatic cool bad guy to the end of
the series
few characters seem to bounce back and
forth between friend and enemy as much
as will simpson played by will traval
does in the first season of jessica
jones his complex journey is as
compelling as it is tumultuous
introduced as a policeman manipulated to
attack trish walker by the mind-bending
abilities of kilgrave simpson tries to
make things up to his victim once he's
free of kilgrave's influence simpson
eventually wins walker's trust but his
road to redemption takes dark turns we
learned that in the military simpson was
a part of some scary experiments
including being given drugs to enhance
his abilities and he begins taking those
drugs once more while they may help him
physically the drugs wreck his sanity
putting him on a collision course with
jessica will reappears in season 2 but
he doesn't last long once again trying
to make up for his crimes simpson tries
to protect trish but he's killed by
jessica's mother
in some ways you could say davos played
by sasha dewan is to danny rand what the
mcu's loki is to thor just as loki is
jealous of the love and admiration all
of asgard feels for the god of thunder
davos envies dany for winning the mantle
of iron fist even more davos hates dany
for what he sees as squandering that
power he's dany's primary antagonist in
season 2 of iron fist going to
increasingly darker lengths to claim
rand's power for his own since davos is
introduced in the first season we get to
watch his descent from danny rand's ally
to his nemesis
i'm not going to give up hope that one
day
you will come back to yourself
dejuan is believable as the villain
known in the comics as the steel serpent
and his conflict with rend is one of the
things that makes iron fist's second
season a vast improvement from the first
while the hand pops up in both daredevil
and iron fist it's finally in the
defenders that we meet its leader
alexandra reed sigourney weaver doesn't
play villains often enough and her time
as alexandra reid is proof weaver is
perfectly chosen as the hand's otherwise
immortal leader who finally feels the
approach of death as read she exudes
power ruthlessness and nothing more than
perhaps some dismissive pity for the
band of heroes trying to stop her sadly
while weaver is one of the best reasons
to watch the defenders that list isn't
very long among other flaws the series
was too short and packed with too many
characters before we hardly get a chance
to enjoy weaver in this villainous role
elektra kills her it's a shame that when
it's weaver's time to join the mcu it
was in a role that didn't have the time
to stretch its legs
sure the first season of iron fist is
probably one of the weakest seasons of
all of marvel's netflix series but as a
bad guy harold meacham is pretty great
the manipulative solitary killer spends
much of the series in his penthouse
plotting and abusing his grown children
then there's the brokenness he brought
to danny's family as he was the one who
arranged for the deaths of danny's
parents david wenham is great as meacham
who delves deeper into insanity as the
season continues caught between iron
fist and the hand one of is likely best
known as boromir's more resilient
brother pharamir in the lord of the
rings films so it's refreshingly
unsettling to see him in a role that
pushes so hard in the other direction
it's too bad the season as a whole
wasn't as good as wenham's performance
alyssa jones played by janet mcteer
never really had much of a chance in
jessica jones's second season we learned
she survived the car crash that killed
her son and husband after which she was
nursed back to health and given powers
by the scientist carl malus by the time
melissa and jessica are reunited
alyssa's dedication to malice reaches a
manic pitch making her dangerous to
anyone near her especially after malice
dies after the much more cerebral and
emotional threat of kilgrave and jessica
jones's first season someone who could
pose more of a physical challenge to the
hero was the obvious choice and mcteer
is wonderful in the role she brings a
fierceness to alyssa that makes you
believe she's capable of anything
including hurting or even killing the
daughter she's just been reunited with
the assassin john pilgrim played by josh
stewart is singular in the ranks of
punisher villains this is for no other
reason than the fact that the guy
actually survives his clash with frank
castle with his priest's collar and the
unsettling calm with which he doles out
violence pilgrim is one of the most
chilling and disturbing villains to show
up in the punisher or any of marvel's
netflix shows we eventually learn that
as skilled as he is at killing pilgrim
is far from being a conscienceless
killer a former member of the aryan
brotherhood pilgrim eventually saw the
evil of his ways converted to
christianity and became a pastor his
bloody rampage through the second season
of the punisher is the result of the
manipulative schultz's keeping his
children hostage it's pilgrim's
dedication to his family that convinces
frank to spare his life in spite of his
crimes
trish walker is perhaps the most tragic
character in any of marvel's netflix
series when we meet her in the first
season of jessica jones she is the
titular hero's best friend and the
survivor of a horrible assault as the
series continues her desire to be more
like jessica leads her to increasingly
dangerous extremes unfortunately this
includes her taking the same addicting
medications that gave the late will
simpson his enhanced abilities surprised
to find herself with powers walker goes
down roads she can't turn back from in
the show's final season she becomes a
self-styled vigilante but her time as a
crime fighter leaves a lot to be desired
among other things she accidentally
causes one attacker to fall on her own
weapon and flees the scene rather than
helping she kills gregory salinger just
before the series finale and the final
battle of jessica jones proves to be
between jones and walker
william rollins played by paul schultz
is precisely the kind of guy frank
castle was born to kill when castle
first meets rollins in afghanistan the
cia agent seems like someone castle is
destined to lock horns with this is even
before castle learns that rollins and
schooner are using their squad to
smuggle heroin back to the united states
it's also rollins who orders the hit on
castle's life leading to deaths of his
wife and their two children so
inevitably it is rollins who meets his
own brutal end at castle's hands before
the punisher's first season is over with
his freezing glare and permanent scowl
paul schultz is utterly believable as
the corrupt operative who left his
conscience far behind long ago he's the
perfect villain for the punisher's
inaugural season and his heir of cold
arrogance clashes wonderfully with the
more likable villainy of frank castle's
old friend billy russo
what do you say about a man who almost
kills a chef because he doesn't like how
he cooks a steak well you call him
whatever you want just make sure it's
out of his earshot in the final season
of jessica jones jeremy bob plays
gregory salinger a serial killer who
targets anyone he views as being morally
bankrupt or unworthy of their place in
society could be bad chefs blackmailers
or superpowered private detectives
salinger is highly intelligent and has
spent his life honing the different
skills he would need to be a prolific
serial killer but as challenging an
enemy as he is to jessica jones his
crushing self-loathing and self-doubt
shine through more than anything else
it's clear that no matter how much he
accomplishes or what he proves himself
capable of the voices inside salinger
will never allow it to be enough
and that
is extraordinary
in the third season of daredevil
benjamin poindexter played by wilson
bethel is an fbi agent who wilson fisk
manipulates into becoming his worst self
bethel plays a man who's learned to
manage his mental illness fisk learns
poindexter's coping skills and works to
tear them all down so that all
poindexter is left with is madness as a
killer poindexter is arguably the
greatest physical challenge murdock
faces in the course of his series
poindexter's backstory was an addition
not found in his comic character where
he goes by bullseye he is never directly
referred to as bullseye in the show
however the end of season 3 strongly
hinted that we were going to see the
return of the former fbi agent were the
series to have continued maybe he would
have come back as bullseye
guess we'll never know
few villains change as drastically
between seasons as the punishers billy
russo played by ben barnes in the
beginning of the first season of the
punisher russo acts like frank castle's
friend but we soon learned he was in bed
with rollins and schooner in the
cerberus squad of all of castle's
enemies from his special ops days russo
is the only one to survive the first
season but he doesn't do it unscathed
castle leaves russo with the scars that
earn him the name jigsaw traumatized by
his confrontation with castle russo
temporarily loses all memory of the last
few years in the punisher's second
season here actor ben barnes shows us a
more vulnerable side of jigsaw who
spends months recovering mentally and
physically ultimately billy russo acts
true to form seducing his therapist and
building a new gang of crooks and
killers but castle gives russo the death
he deserves in the end in his final
moments russo apologizes to his old
friend but castle hardly seems to care
it isn't tough to imagine how cornell
stokes aka cottonmouth won the loyalty
of the crooks under his command along
with the more obvious threats and
incentives someone like stokes would use
to build a criminal organization of all
the villains we meet in luke cage he has
the most magnetic personality mahershala
ali's brilliant performance is
mesmerizing enough that you actually
believe the confidence of that big laugh
of his it doesn't matter that one
confrontation after another shows he has
no good ideas about how to handle luke
cage his death at mariah dillard's hands
in the middle of the first season is
that much more shocking because of ali's
work even as mariah furiously finishes
him off with a mic stand it's tough to
believe the series is getting rid of one
of its most entertaining characters so
soon
bushmaster played by mustafa shakir is
the first villain in luke cage to give
the titular hero any kind of physical
challenge without the help of judas
bullets or power suits in the opening
moments of season two's i get physical
bushmaster leaves luke cage unconscious
on the harlem sidewalk using only his
martial arts skills his speed and his
enhanced strength the brooklyn native
uses the jamaican herb nightshade to
boost his strength and durability
rendering his skin almost as impervious
as cages bushmaster is a clever
charismatic bad guy and it's tough not
to sympathize with him he's in harlem
looking for vengeance on the stokes's
his own family was killed by the late
stokes matriarch mama mabel and her gang
cage and bushmaster eventually forge an
uneasy alliance to stop mariah dillard
but it ends when bushmaster proves more
willing to resort to murder than cage
would like
two episodes before wilson fisk appears
in daredevil's first season were
introduced to his most trusted advisor
james wesley played by toby leonard
moore well-dressed soft-spoken and
eloquent wesley is likely one of the
last men you'd guess is a high-ranking
member in a violent criminal
organization
yet in his first scene wesley calmly
sits on a park bench next to a man who
owes fisk money and delivers a monstrous
threat against the man's daughter i see
this man here
if we're being honest with each other mr
farnam i find his methods
unpleasant
it's because wesley isn't the guy who
works with guns or knives that he's such
a great villain he delivers his blows
with a word or a look wesley represents
the more civilized side of wilson fisk
the part of himself that the crime lord
wants the world to see that's a big part
of the reason why when karen page kills
wesley fisk begins to do away with his
photogenic facade and deal with his
enemies much more brazenly
while it wasn't enough to save the
series iron fist's second season is a
vast improvement on the first one of the
things that makes season 2 so much
better is alice eve's portrayal of the
mentally fractured mary walker every
scene she's in makes you worry about
what she might do employed by joy
meacham first to follow danny rand and
then to get more hands on walker is one
of the most intimidating and challenging
foes rand faces in the series in spite
of having no enhanced abilities through
skill and careful planning mary wipes
the floor with dany rand in their first
fight on a subway platform in target
iron fist
madame gao played by wai ching-ho is one
of the most dangerous people you'll meet
in marvel's netflix shows she presents
herself as a physically frail elderly
woman in order to give enemies and
allies alike a false sense of security
she prefers to work from the shadows
letting her actions speak for her and
foregoing the noise and bravado of other
bad guys while she tends to be a puppet
master more than anything else we learn
in the defenders that gal has physical
abilities that allow her to go
toe-to-toe with iron fist
not only is madame gao one of the
strongest pieces of connective tissue
throughout marvel's netflix series she's
perhaps the absolute last person you
want to mess with she may not lash out
in aggressive and bloody ways but she'll
give you that wicked smile and just wait
until the time is right
in the first half of luke cage's first
season mariah dillard wants harlem to
see her as the legitimate face of the
stove's family so she allows cornell to
lord over the criminal elements of the
neighborhood things change when he
implies the sexual abuse dillard endured
at the hands of her uncle was consensual
she kills cornell in his club and
supported by the manipulative shades
soon becomes the queen of crime in
harlem alfree woodard may have already
had a role in the mcu as a grieving
mother in 2016's captain america civil
war however her performance in luke cage
overrides any concerns a continuity
stickler might have through woodard
mariah is a tortured villain haunted by
the abuse she suffered from her criminal
family her rage and pain is bubbling at
the surface of every scene and she's
merciless enough to leave no mystery as
to how she could ever be a threat to a
man with bulletproof skin
few of marvel's netflix villains could
leave such a lasting impression as
jessica jones's kilgrave played by david
tennant gifted with the ability to make
anyone do what he tells them kilgrave
makes every character a potential time
bomb before the events of the series he
uses his powers to force jessica jones
to do a lot of things she doesn't want
to do including commit murder the trauma
she suffers at his hands is what makes
the hero so miserable and his presence
is felt throughout the show's amazing
first season even long before he and
jessica finally reunite face to face
david tennant's performance is such that
even though jones kills him in the
season 1 finale he never fully leaves
the series kilgrave leaves scars in
jessica too deep to let him die for good
we see this most clearly in season two's
aka three lives and counting when jones
is plagued by visions of kilgrave
harassing her and tempting her to lash
out with violence
it's unthinkable to imagine someone
other than vincent d'onofrio in the role
of daredevil's most important villain
wilson fisk for the show's three seasons
which is more than most of the marvel
netflix series got and yet hardly feels
like enough d'onofrio's time as fisk was
one of the best reasons to watch
daredevil d'onofrio provides the perfect
mix of intelligence civility
ruthlessness rage and turbulent pain to
bring us the man the comic books call
the kingpin it's probably not a
coincidence that season 2 is generally
regarded as the weakest chapter of
daredevil since fisk is mostly absent he
only appears in the final moments of the
season's eighth episode guilty as sin
wilson fisk embodies the incredible
potential of the stories that were being
told on netflix's marvel shows fisk is
no alien warlord or an asgardian god
jealous of his brother he's a man of
wealth whose childhood scars drive him
to evil and nothing about that sounds
like make-believe there's no reason why
someone like wilson fisk couldn't exist
in the real world and that makes him
more terrifying than any other mcu
villain you can think of
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes and villains
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]